they want to inflict maximum pain they
want as much collateral damage as
humanly possible because they don't want
anyone around Donald Trump they don't
want him to have a circle of people he
can trust he can rely on who can go out
there I mean if you look at this case
right now he's been in court over the
past two days this Leticia James AG case
every person had testified that my
husband Eric and my brother-in-law Don
had nothing to do with any of these
valuations and yet they got dragged into
it too why would she do that maximum
pain I mean to me it's so much of what
that January 6 committee sham nonsense
was which was it wasn't really about
anything other than warning people if
you dare step out of line again you
could be on the hot seat neck don't ever
question anything this government does
or tells you to do again because next
time it could be you it might be Donald
Trump today next time it could be you
and it will be I'll give you an example
of how of the game they're playing when
it comes to the the the judge in the in
this Trump lawsuit AOC made a video
after January 6 where she said someone
banged on her door she went and hid in
the bathroom Heard a Voice say where is
she where is she she thought she was
going to die and all that stuff what she
was doing was making you believe
that she thought rioters broke into her
office immediately conservative said her
office isn't even in the Capitol
Building to which the media responded
there are tunnels connecting it and then
this one surprised the heck out of me
her I I I I I did the whole timeline I
fact checked everything and I said
her story took place one hour before the
capital was even breached
she was she was manipulating the context
of the day most people did not know the
timeline the only thing they knew was
that on January 6 people stormed the
capital so when she says on January 6th
someone banged on my door and I was
scared she is lying to you because she
knows you don't understand the basic
context around this day what this judge
is doing is very very similar he says
the tax assessor says the property is
only worth around 18 to 20 million at
Mar-A-Lago Trump is inflating the value
of his properties he's committing fraud
what do regular people here who don't
pay attention judge rules Trump
committed fraud but here's the funny
thing anybody paying attention
immediately recognizes the problem here
depending on how deep you go in terms of
paying attention if you're someone like
me I just pull up the actual property of
the comparables in in Palm Beach and
West Palm Beach and I'm like Mar-A-Lago
17 and a half acres from from Beach to
Beach and a third acre goes for you know
10 or 30 million dollars with a house on
it a lot that's just half acre is like
10 20 million dollars how is Mar-A-Lago
as as just land worth less than this
however anybody with a cursory
understanding of real estate knows the
values aren't set by the individual it's
appraised by the lender exactly when you
mention Eric and don't have nothing to
do with the evaluation right the bank
comes in and says here's what we think
yeah they have their own due diligence
they they have a fiduciary
responsibility to send someone in
they're not going to take my word for it
if I'm like yeah I got a house down the
street it's worth 10 billion dollars you
can trust me on that of course they have
to look out for themselves as a business
at the end of the day that's the crazy
part of all of the this and you're right
the the truth is that the average person
out there probably doesn't understand
this kind of minutia right all they
cared about and all they have ever cared
about is that headline Donald Trump and
the word fraud next to it and that's it
that's the end game for them they want
to inflict maximum damage to him they
want to tie him up but Luke you said it
I do believe it's making him stronger I
feel like all of this stuff has shaken
people awake that mug shot forget it
that mug shot was probably the biggest
mistake they ever made the number of
people who have approached me post mug
shot and been like you know what I
really have never paid attention to
politics I wasn't sure I liked Donald
Trump but that mug shot somehow to some
people represented A system that had
been failing them that was broken that
was working against them working against
Donald Trump and they were like wait a
minute I see what they're doing to this
guy and now their their eyes are open
and they're not going to be closed and
it actually unified a nation the
Democrats really like that and the
Republicans really liked it I made it
t-shirt of it right away
um and a lot of people were buying it on
the left and on the right it didn't
matter but but more importantly every
time they do go after Trump you see his
poll numbers go up and and right now
he's he's higher than he was this entire
election cycle even though he's saying
some kind of very interesting things but
uh just for yourself I'm kind of curious
as a trump do you feel like you're under
a spotlight do you feel like you're
targeted do you feel like someone is
just waiting to see if you're going to
do anything wrong just so they could
blow it up in the media every single
second of every single day absolutely
yeah I mean these people are disgusting
and to be honest with you if it if it
weren't my family and I hadn't had
first-hand experience with this sort of
stuff I would say this is I mean that's
really overblown there's no way but it's
true they they pick apart anything that
any of us do they try to attack us for
it and and honestly you really think
that if any of us had I don't know
obtained a firearm illegally and lied on
a federal gun application and then
thrown the gun a garbage can next to a
school we wouldn't be locked up right
now get the heck out of here that's the
that's the frustrating thing is the
clear double standard that exists
between someone with the last name Trump
and someone with the last name or just
you know smoked crack and uh you know
that's what ladies of the night and you
know took photos of themselves doing it
uh I mean I mean there's controversy on
on both you know sides there but it's
just absolutely crazy how far the media
will go and how um they will just in
many instances make stuff up in order to
try to frame you guys as really hard you
want a great example what I was going to
ask you what's one of the craziest ways
that the media has attacked you that had
no reality
um at all so last year we had a
hurricane come through the state the
hurricane hit the western side of the
State of Florida I live on the east
coast of Florida so anyone with a little
knowledge of Hurricane knows there are
bands of rain that come through and in
between those bands it's clear it's fine
my kids were cooped up inside they
canceled school that day okay so I took
my kids and my dogs just down the
neighborhood on a little walk in between
the bands of rain my son was on one of
these little like motorized tractor
things that he had and I took a video
because all of a sudden we got poured on
out of nowhere with the rain I posted it
on social media people were calling for
child protective services I'm not even
joking to come to my house there were
multiple stories written about how I was
an unfit mother I mean it is it's so
insane I yeah that that's one of the
probably least faves of of my past
couple years it's getting crazy huh dude
yeah yes but I was as you guys were
talking firstly you got caught in the
rain with your kid that's that's I guess
normal I said I caught I capped I
captioned a character building
experience because it is sometimes it
rains sometimes it rains people like
she's putting her child in danger in a
hurricane oh my God okay this uh build
back better which is like a world
economic Forum thing then Biden starts
saying it okay is it not that's not a
coincidence humans well he got made fun
of by who was a Boris Johnson for for
stealing build back better I just
constantly so so the Brits were doing it
too it's yeah if this this like
organized four different indictments
unrelated all and like within the course
of like six months on Donald Trump it's
not that's not a coincidence well the
day after a hunter Biden or Joe Biden
big information drop happened something
yeah but understand it's a standalone
complex and a conspiracy so there's the
bigger picture which is all these
indictments happening I don't think you
need New York to coordinate with Georgia
and the federal government these are
people who have Trump derangement
syndrome who are going to do these
things of their own volition in fact as
soon as the feds make a move then George
is like now's our chance now we can pile
on
some of this stuff like right every time
Hunter bides indicted there's like a UFO
leak or some new indictment of trump
comes out that seems coordinated and a
group of people organizing that at a
high level but all of the attacks on
Trump it's because these people are
deranged and they're going to keep doing
it that's look you look at what happened
to Brett Kavanaugh with uh that woman
sweat neck I think her name was yeah
accusing him of being at parties where
they would line up outside of rooms to
take turns
but just you know having their way with
women against their will keep it as
family friendly as I can
he didn't no one came to her and told
her to say it right or my assumption is
that maybe I'm wrong it's just that
these people are so deranged they're
like I'll just do it and they come out
of their own volition and it looks
coordinated when it often isn't man I
spent my youth believing in people that
they would be honest I just thought like
if you're good and honest then more
people will be good and honest then we
can make a good and honest society and
then I'm learning in my midlife that
deceitfulness and evil is like the way
to lead like it throughout history
that's how they've been doing it they
kill their opponents they take control
and they say that they were the good
guys yeah there's that tweet I
referenced about that it was a video of
hyenas eating some kind of ungulate
alive they were they were eating it from
the belly eviscerating it and the Tweet
said it is not the case that the most
vicious and evil people are punished in
fact nature shows us that they are often
rewarded and that was the point that you
watch this poor like it was like a
wildebeach or something struggling to
get up being devoured alive and yeah
there's an old as an old hacker joke
sound if you're not cheating you're not
trying I understand Jesus in a way from
the Bible like what they said that he
was just like they don't know what
they're doing man and you just let it
happen because like what can you do it
gets to a point where like I'm not going
to become evil at least I don't want to
so like how do I how do I really help
Society without becoming evil yeah how
much crazier do you think it's going to
get because I think we're we're you know
in the middle of the election cycle but
I I think it's going to get crazier I
agree what do you think is going to
happen because we have the indictments
we have the court hearings but they're
not stopping Trump they're making him
more popular I really do believe we're
we're in an inroad where the system is
becoming more and more desperate how
desperate do you think they will become
well I think they they become more
desperate by the day because I think you
know you look at who they're running on
the Democrat side Joe Biden and
apparently Kamala Harris two of the uh
lowest polling favorability uh I mean
president vice president in history
these two are just absolutely horrible
one worse than the other they have a big
problem on their hands they have no
bench on the Democrat side we seem to
have a little bit of a bench on the
other other side of the aisle but I
think they're getting more desperate by
the day because it must be so
frustrating to see all the effort
they're putting out against one guy and
it's boomeranging back and it is having
the opposite of the intended result for
them so I I'm sure it's going to get a
lot worse thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you on next time